um obviously as you're doing this
decentralized network uh people have to
get paid
right and so um there's this uh storage
token right s-t-o-r-j or um i think is
what it is
um and they're you know these tokens
have become
controversial in the uh crypto industry
the bitcoin community thinks you know
why not use bitcoin
uh everybody else thinks why not use xyz
token
like just talk a little bit about um the
use of
this payment via a digital token or
digital currency and then kind of why
create your own versus use one that
already existed sure
sure so we um uh
you know as i said sort of clarify you
at least the way our economic model
works right now we
quote prices in dollars both for
customers and for
uh the snows with the suppliers uh and
then customers can either pay us in fiat
or in
our token uh and our suppliers get paid
in token and we
do a sort of spot conversion based off
of these systems
um but there are a lot of reasons why
it's great for us first of all again
we're
we are now paying thousands of people in
85 plus countries
right uh sometimes small amounts
sometimes large amounts being able to do
it with
uh using our token being able to use
things like smart contracts really
really critical
we've also programmatically built in not
only on the supply side but on the
demand side
so we've built a program we call it the
open source partner program
that also kind of turns things on the
head in terms of demand sides rather
than
hiring lots of sales people as you
talked about the centralized people
doing and then
you know essentially what the cloud
providers tend to do with the open
source
community is take great open source code
uh give it away for free
you know as a loss leader to drive more
compute and storage networking
we actually compensate the open source
company as a company so if they send
users and data our way we send money
back to them and we do it
programmatically
so for us it makes the system work much
faster much more
reliably of course we we funded our
initial efforts um for a large extent
uh based off of having a successful
token sale back in in may of 2017.
um and uh for us
it's the right way to do things uh it
also gives us
um an opportunity to also further
differentiate ourselves we're trying to
be
um not only sort of enterprise-grade in
terms of our storage but also
enterprise-grade in terms of the
governance and management
got it and so do you feel like
eventually
this is gonna force kind of digital
currencies what regardless of which one
it ends up being
uh into um kind of this entire cloud and
storage world where
whether you are a decentralized or
centralized platform like they've got to
support it
or do you feel like you've got kind of
an advantage and kind of a wedge into a
market
where that's not going to happen for a
long time and you guys will kind of
enjoy the the first mover advantage
there
uh yes it's a good question i mean we uh
uh you know i don't know whether the uh
the crypto aspect of what we do ends up
being a barrier to entry or not
um i suspect that if it doesn't it's
it's less important than the
decentralized aspect of what we do
right i i mean we sort of internally say
uh you know um
you know blockchain is much bigger than
cryptocurrency decentralization is much
bigger than
blockchain and we think that's like
decentralized infrastructure in general
is much bigger than any of them that's
really the powerful thing
is that you give tools that push things
to the edge if you will and
push push infrastructure into the hands
of you know thousands hopefully
millions of people you know around the
planet um
and that's really the big disruption and
and
cryptocurrency and blockchain these are
all sort of primitives that enable that
but they're not the main story yeah and
one of the things that's really
interesting just in
computing in general to me is the
centralized players
have been trying to build kind of
pseudo-decentralized networks
that they control right what i mean by
that is all of these pops and kind of
localized
data centers and kind of infrastructure
that for those that are unfamiliar with
the space
uh they basically are just pushing
infrastructure from rather than having
one data center
in the us or or in one area how do we
kind of break it up and put it closer to
the user
but they still control it it feels like
it's already moving in the direction of
decentralization from an infrastructure
standpoint just
the ownership has stayed centralized you
guys really are saying hey we have
decentralized
ownership of the network and we have
decentralized infrastructure and
therefore that's the advantage right
right right and also we've designed
things so that you know we're not a
central point of failure right so for
example like if you're storing data with
us
we don't have any of the keys we have no
way of knowing what's being stored
uh no way of mining it no way of uh
compromising it and the same thing true
for the storage note operators so
you know one sort of sort of
clarification
about how things work with us if you
upload a file to us to store it with us
it gets encrypted so scrambled up with
keys that only you have
it then gets split up into lots of
pieces uh generally about 80 pieces
of which any 30 can use put it back in
each of those 80 pieces goes to a
different drive
run by different person on different
power supply and a different geographic
location
and that level of decentralization does
magic into security magic in terms of
performance magic in terms of uh of
economics as well right
and and that's really the key right it's
not that
we have created a network where we push
stuff out to the edge
we've enabled the network it's at the
edge
that's awesome um and to me like you
know yeah
i'm biased uh because i kind of
understood this more and more and more
but uh
it just feels like naturally this is
where the world has to head right like
you guys are just ahead
ahead of the curve yeah yeah no i i
think i think it has to write and i
think i think
this decentralized approach is really
the only way to create a viable
alternative to the centralized providers
and it's good a job they do and by the
way they they offer great services right
but
um you know again if data is the new oil
we don't we don't want we don't want
another rockefeller
and it's just a bad thing if if cloud
computing which is the most important
computing trend
uh is dominated by you know three of the
five largest companies by market cap
that's and nobody else can get in that
that's just that's a bad
bad situation